je m'appelle alain giguère et j'ai 11
ans j'aime la danse le théâtre et le
piano et en curieuse de nature je me
pose beaucoup des questions sur
plusieurs sujets aussi différents les
uns des autres
ayant grandi avec un grand froid vous si
créatif que moi il ya c'est respirer le
sujet de ma présentation les lego
permettent aux gens de développer
plusieurs capacités tout en juin avec
les bleus bonjour aujourd'hui je vais
présenter montagnes désertiques au fait
quand ils impactent qui s'adonnent sur
la société
mon thème et les les durant cette
présentation
je vais vous parler de son inventeur
quel est l'impact et je veux vous en
apprendre plus sur les goûts j'ai choisi
ce thème parce que j'aime comme illégaux
et lorsque j'étais plus jeune je jouais
beaucoup aussi parce que je trouve
qu'ils ont un tel impact sur la société
l'imagination et la créativité
c'est de là que viennent toutes les ut
les idées de mon amant un peu de sang
les ventes en son nom et au les cuirs
tricia il admirait 7 avril 1891 à
fiscaux il était le fils d'une famille
d'agriculteurs pauvres du gipn dans
l'ouest et d'allemand en 1932
ces thèmes a été formé mais n'diaye a
commencé à fabriquer des jouets en bois
pour gagner sa vie
après avoir perdu son emploi de vielles
charpentier engageant matière place et
il fait alors des versions miniatures de
maisons et devait donc tout commence en
1932 avec un morceau de bois le long de
la société créée par ole qu'il en 1932 à
partir du danois led diodes signifiant
joue bien et en latin jacent si vous
avez bien compris
au début c'était tout un mois plus tard
voilà du plastique en 1949
l'entreprise produit plus de 200 jouets
en plastique et en voir si on devine
délai vous l'entreprise a déjà été aussi
l'un des plus importants maintenant les
pactes la vérité mon fait et bien sûr
les légumes l'accroché quand l'impact
que les lego on sera société et que les
gens qui juin se développer leur
créativité car on crée des choses avec
les lego la patience car ça en vain
non construction ça demande beaucoup des
princes des patients ça toute la sphère
l'imagination car justement on invente
quelque chose l'habilité car à force de
manipuler tous tes fesses on devient
plus habiles et finalement l'intelligent
pour que lacoste son marché skoda
mettait mécanisme quelle pièce et c'est
notre président fabriqué les goûts de
façon plus économique
surf art pipette pièce ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent maintenant voici un but sur
plus des formats sa survie les lego est
une gamme de jouets de construction
ils sont fabriqués par le groupe d'anna
des lego et les boues sont composés des
briques emboîtables des figurines et
d'hiver avec ses jouets on peut faire
des villes des bâtiments et même dire au
bout on peut faire pour quelque chose
mais on peut monter quelque chose'
palace était démontée pour faire quelque
chose de plusieurs personnes aiment les
les
autant les plus jeunes crise a dit
l'entreprise a déjà été classé dans
l'entreprise la plus puissante au monde
par les cabinets boeing china - ma
famille lorsque j'étais plus jeune on
est allé en floride et on est rentré
dans un bâtiment avec peu de dégoût on
peut même en fabriquer j'ai déjà plus
avancé qu'il faut des maquettes à toute
la ville
oui et collectionne pour faire des
villages en lego moi et ma famille en a
même vu des géants allemands allez-vous
beaucoup d'en connaître maintenant les
goûts évoluent beaucoup sont vraiment
des versions ya le pôle hi-fi pour l'ego
qui pour les plus jeunes donc voilà
grâce à notre imagination et créativité
nous avons plein d'idées
merci et bonne soirée